[Music]
what up guys goes on here for anime
uproar I'm very happy about this video
in particular if you recall last video I
told you guys to vote for the next MH a
fact video on Instagram and Twitter
the response was awesome and we got
around 500 votes altogether now
Kirishima is one of my favourite
characters that I made shape but I never
thought he would get the most votes but
to my surprise he did and so I'm psyched
about that second and third place were
extremely close one vote separated by
kugo who got second and fumika gay who
got third so I'm gonna create a story on
Instagram where you guys can vote for
who you want to see next stories only
last for 24 hours so make sure to go
vote ASAP if you like these MH a fact
videos make sure to text the smash that
like button to let me know and if by
some bizarre circumstance you have yet
to subscribe lined up for another Texas
smash and hit that subscribe button and
ring the magical YouTube bell to become
a member of the notification nah c'mon
now without further ado let's get into
this manly video fact number one what e
course she always tries to make the
names of characters at MH a meaningful
so that they reflect the character in
some way for instance even a name like
Tatsu Tatsu Tatsu Tatsu which seems kind
of bizarre has significance not only
does his name contain the kanji for iron
which reflects his quirk the redundant
nature of his name nods towards how
similar he and his quirk are to kitty
Shima
he's like an iron clone so through his
name the Creator horikoshi points fun at
how unoriginal and similar he is when
compared to Kitty schewe in a zeros case
his name contains the kanji for cut and
sharp
this reflects Kitty she was quark which
is pretty straightforward it hardens his
skin and he can use it to create sharp
and strong body parts for instance his
hair can become sharp as well as his
fingers and this leads us to
number two Kirishima has a scar on his
right eye which is pretty hard to notice
the word cut which is also part of agios
name has significance when we consider
Katie Sheila's backstory and how he got
the scar on his right eye
horikoshi does a pretty good job of
telling the stories so I'll quote him
here he writes it happened when Kitty
Shima was three he was sleeping in bed
when suddenly bitten by the urge to pee
he awoke and rubbed his eyes and it was
then that his squirt rose the worst time
to manifest for the first time and quote
so perhaps it's not as exciting as
getting bitten by a radioactive spider
but that is the origin of Pyramus quirk
he rubbed his eye which he must have
done countless times before but this
time his heartening quirk activated and
he cut his eye luckily not deep enough
to blind him but enough to leave a
lifelong scar on his face interestingly
enough horikoshi has admitted that even
he overlooks Konishi Mo's scar and often
forgets to drive in the manga fact
number three like a lot of other
characters Kirishima underwent some
changes since horikoshi came up with his
initial design some of you may recall
from the deku video that dec lose hair
initially went over his right eye but he
just looked like he needed a haircut so
horikoshi decided against it
similarly in krishna's case his hair
also seemed to change a bit his initial
hairdo looked kind of like a cross
between his usual hair and his
unbreakable form hair he looked a bit
more sinister too and his pants sag
lower than they do now his middle school
hair underwent a change too and his scar
used to be on his left eye and was much
more pronounced to be honest I totally
think the initial design was awesome too
even if it was a little rough around the
edges but I liked the final outcome as
well in his initial design he looked
like he had a more Baku go esque
personality but he turned out to be a
very warm and all-around stand-up guy
what Eco she even said that many times
when he is working on rough drafts he is
quietly saved by Kenny Shima which shows
how special he ended up being for the
creator himself what he cost she liked
us
needs a dose of Manliness that Kirishima
provides fact number four one last thing
about kadhi Shima's hair it doesn't
naturally look like it does in the anime
for starters konnichiwa dyes it red is
not actually his natural hair color his
natural hair color appears to be black
in the manga but he dies it along with
his eyebrows apparently his hair is also
not naturally spiked up in the manga
middle school kid eeschema reveals that
he thinks he's kind of dull and boring
while heroes in modern times are
supposed to look flashy and stand out so
they can get higher approval ratings so
he eventually decides to make himself
stand out more by dyeing his hair and
spiking it up what he core she tells us
that his hair style takes three minutes
to set up his rent and spiky hair style
along with his hero named red riot is
also an homage to his favorite pro hero
crimson riot as is the case with crimson
riot kitty Shima appears to be able to
harden his hair using his quirk this is
especially obvious in his Super Saiyan 2
form also called unbreakable fact number
5
Kirishima is one of the most popular
characters in the show and his
popularity has only been increasing as
the manga goes on in the Japanese
shounen jump poles he got 15 place in
the first pole then jumped all the way
to fifth place in the second and rose
again to 4th in the third only being
beaten out by Todoroki deku and baku go
I've said it before and I'll say it
again this show is full of so many
likable characters they're reaching such
a high position is truly impressive
across the seas in the first u.s.
popularity poll Kirishima got 16th place
and then he moved up to 9th place in the
second pole in crunchy rolls 2018
popularity poll he placed 12th between
momoyo zoo and toaru kagaku day but i'm
sure as the anime catches up to the
manga material he will only move up in
the ratings I gotta say his backstory
has got to be my favorite in the whole
series so definitely look forward to
that if you haven't read the manga yet
let's just say Kirishima story tapped
into some of my manly emotions as I read
it and even though I already know it I'm
still more than pumped to see it
animated now onward
to fact number six for this fact let's
take a look at kitty she was official
stats according to the data book
Kaneesha ma has pretty good statistics
overall although he is not exceptional
in any single area he scored a four out
of five in power a three out of five and
speed a three out of five in technique a
three out of five in intelligence and a
4 out of 5 in cooperativeness not
surprisingly condition most stats are
exactly the same as his Silver Surfer
clone Tatsu Tatsu Kanishka is not the
least intelligent student in the class
for instance electric Saitama over here
scored a 1 out of 5 and intelligence but
Kadesh was still near the bottom of the
class placing 15th in class 1a s overall
grades his high cooperativeness level is
significant though since he is one of
the few characters who can easily make
friends with other students as well as
with Baku go who is so lousy at getting
along with others that he scored a lowly
one out of five in cooperativeness we'll
talk more about this epic friendship
later on but for now let's move on to
fact number seven in the original
Japanese
Kirishima is voiced by the 28 year old
toshiaki Masuda who also voice acted in
high q-- and one punch man but read riot
is definitely the most manly character
he's ever voiced fact number eight in
the English dub Kirishima is voiced by
the 36 year old Justin Ryan cook who was
born in Austin Texas and if that's not
another sign for everyone to Texas smash
that like button right now I don't know
what is cook voice multiple characters
in the Dragon Ball series including the
good dende the bad Raddatz and the ugly
evil boo he also voiced you skate in Yu
Yu Hakusho a shown in classic that I
have yet to watch let me know if you
recommend you you hakusho in the
comments and let me know if Kitty
schmoes voice is more manly in the
Japanese or in the English fact number
nine Karishma comes from Chiba
Prefecture and the only other character
from class 1a that also comes from the
same place as Mina
they both even attended the same middle
school now let's talk about these
to for a second these two have history
Karishma looked up to me not in middle
school not only did she look like a hero
she acted like one too
while Kenny Shima hesitated in fear
Minah jumped in to protect her
classmates from a villain kind of like
Deku moving without thinking
however Karishma isn't naturally like
this so he decides to change himself
along with his image in high school so
he doesn't live a life of regrets and
revert back to the way he was before
by the way that's what I love about
creation was character the fact that he
doesn't seem to be a born hero but is
nonetheless able to compensate for that
through manly hardwork and willpower
anyways Minah notices the change in him
when they both get to you a and she
agrees to support him and keep his old
ways a secret from the other students
and now the most important question let
me know in the comments if you ship or
skip these two horn buddies along with
the backstory what of course she posted
a cute sketch of the two together on
Twitter after he posted a cute sketch of
Todoroki at Momo together
another popular ship so it seems like
horikoshi is hinting at something here
but we'll have to wait and see for the
record I don't just ship it I Detroit
ship it fact number 10 as usual and set
up one fact fact number 10 will be a
lightning round of random fact where I
shoot out as many bonus facts as I can
three two one less Jam Kirishima was
born on October 16th which makes him a
Libra just like me yet another reason
for me to like him not that I needed
another one especially since he already
had my favorite color in his hero name
his blood type is o and he is 170
centimeters or 5 foot 7 inches tall
although if we count his spiked up hair
he's approaching eda at 179 centimeters
or 5 foot 10 and half inches tall
Kirishima likes manly things of course
and meat which probably falls under the
umbrella term manly but must be stated
nonetheless apologies to the vegetarians
out there but Kanishka probably wouldn't
consider you manly kiowa goes through
toothbrushes quickly which is not
surprising since it looks like he has
shark teeth it's also no surprise he
likes meat so much since it looks like
all of his teeth are k9t
which means he's a natural pro at
tearing off chunks of that precious meat
it's almost like he's a carnivorous
manly dinosaur in the form of a high
school kid lastly what Akashi says if
you look closely
Kirishima was kind of introduced as
early as chapter 3 I think I may have
found him but let me know if you know
for sure what page he's on it's the
manliest game of Where's Waldo ever and
that is the fact portion of this video
now let's go beyond plus ultra and gear
up for the common corner where before
each one of these MH a FAQ videos I
asked you guys on Instagram to tell me
what your favorite thing about the
character in question is last time I was
blown away when OSHA Co got over 100
comments and this post got an even more
impressive 180 comments so thank you so
much to everyone that shared their
thoughts let's read some of them right
now pay is a obviously got the right
answer when she said everything but
let's look at some other responses just
for fun a lot of you enjoyed his dynamic
with other characters for instance
hunter likes how hard for all is able to
get along with everyone by the way bonus
points for making me laugh with that
ingenious triple entendre eros loved his
fight with Tatsu Tatsu Tatsu Tatsu I
concur manly and passionate steel versus
manly and passionate hardening
definitely made for a manly and
passionate match it was an extremely
hard match for kitty Shima to be sure
and even though it was a quick side
fight I definitely enjoyed it king libra
loves the relationship between c'mon
Bakugan and a lot of you loved this
friendship me included king libra
continues saying watching season 3
seeing him reach his hand to baku go as
he vaulted up to escape the league and
villains had put tears in my eyes and
that's what this show is really good at
triggering those fields and making us
cry like deku but I agree 100% that that
scene was awesome
and especially how it had to be kioshima
who has somehow managed to befriend the
unfriend of all King explosion murder
truly a bromance for the ages a lot of
you also reference other shows in your
comments
star it gives kiddush my bonus points
because he would be communist younger
brother and I definitely noticed the
parallels both strive to personify the
epitome of manliness laser lousy said
that Kazuma is so manly that he had to
reevaluate Metapod and his hardening
ability the anime dude strikes again
saying that KD Shima seems like the type
of man that'd eat nails for breakfast
without any milk that would put him on
par with this guy and this guy and let's
just say you definitely don't want to
mess with them Dragonball stuff and
memes right I like that his favourite
hero is crimson riot I also loved this
because although all mine is awesome
I feel like too much emphasis has been
placed on him and he seemed to be
everybody's favorite hero for me the
fact that creation was favored here is
crimson ride instead sets him apart for
me and also makes the world of Heroes
seem bigger than I used to I personally
also loved crimson ride and all his
awesome manly quotes in fact I am
seriously considering getting a
custom-made crimson ride poster right
now and next we got one of the most
eloquent posts I've ever read from
Sparky roses they write his manly
manliness has its own level of manliness
because he is such a man well said
indeed lastly and on a less sarcastic
note most importantly a lot of you liked
how creation my developed as a person
and to be honest this is my favorite
thing about Kirishima too for example
pimp shrimp writes I think he's really
made more progress as a hero than anyone
else
Deku for example always had the heart of
a hero but Kirishima really had to look
at his shortcomings and change to be
someone who could make the world a
better place
Kaneesha was truly a self-made hero
rather than a naturally born one and
it's true that dec who was born
quicklist but he acted without thinking
when someone was in trouble in that
sense he was always a natural-born hero
however if you know his backstory
kishima wasn't he underwent a complete
transformation because he was inspired
by crimson riot who also was not a
natural born hero for both of them they
use freezing up in the
asked and who they used to be as
motivation for never letting it happen
again and in my opinion a character like
that is much more relatable a character
like that motivates us and shows us that
deep identity level change is possible
and within our power
and that's why seeing how can you Shiva
has evolved and continues to evolve is
hands-down my favorite thing about him
and that closes off the common corner
and today's video thank you guys so much
for watching I hope I did justice to one
of my favorite characters in one of my
favorite shows make sure to vote on
instagram at anime up roar for the next
video open a comment with that link I'm
super psyched to see if the dark fumika
gay or the explosive Baku go will win
also feel free to leave suggestions for
future videos in the comments but make
sure to take a look at the new MHA facts
playlist which I'll link at the end of
this video so that you don't request a
character that's already been done if
you did like this video give that like
button and unbreakable Texas smash and
subscribe you can harden your
subscription by ringing that magic
YouTube Bell enjoying the notification
na kama the most open Akuma surfing on
the world wide web anyways until next
time see you space cowboys
[Music]
you